this is probably the most excited i've
ever been to eat one of these this is
not tv magic y'all
it's so good
[Music]
hi i'm ayo as many of you know i'm a
private chef so usually i have all the
monies but today casey has given me a
new challenge to create a three-course
brunch for six people for 25
i think katie hates me
25 is insane but you know what it's
black history month so i'm thinking i'm
going to go southern get into my roots
so there are going to be some country
sayings there's going to be a little
aave so let's get started for my first
course i chose deviled eggs these are
nacho grandmas deviled eggs they're
going to be a little spicy i'm gonna use
some hot sauce so let's get into it the
best way to get your shell really good
and easy to peel is give it a nice
little soft roll you don't want to break
it up too much and then it just comes
apart for me deviled eggs are the
southern hors d'oeuvres you know this is
what you pass around while you wait
eight hours for your grandmother to
finally finish cooking all right so we
are ready to go so i'm just gonna split
these guys now old school way you cut
them cross this way to make them all
long and all that like i said we're
going to fancy them up just a little bit
so i'm actually going to cut them this
way you actually want to just trim a
little bit off that guy
and they stand up and then i'm going to
just take my yolks out because that is
how you make your filling the other good
thing about having deviled eggs as like
your appetizer is you can make these
things a day ahead two days ahead it's
something you can refrigerate so it's
not like it needs to be like super fresh
so i have three tablespoons of mayo
one tablespoon of dijon told y'all they
were going to be spiffy so i also have a
tablespoon of hot sauce
what kind of hot sauce you like is
really personal to you being from the
felt so you will notice that i am using
crystal hot sauce and i'm also going to
salt to taste but about a teaspoon so
i'm just gonna use a fork and mash all
of this together until it gets pretty
smooth you don't want chunks of egg yolk
and all that good stuff we're actually
gonna transfer these to a piping bag
with a nice star tip just to give them
some grooves some divots make them look
a little interesting just give them a
little swirl you want to fill them up
just over the tip the next thing we're
going to do is really judge them up with
our garnishes so these are my scallions
we're actually going to turn our knife
on a bias and cut them super thin so you
get like long little strips long little
pieces and they're so cute they make
like these little boomerangs
so now i'm gonna garnish our deviled
eggs the paprika shakers usually have
like these really big holes so i'm
actually going to open it and just put a
little bit in my hand and we're going to
give them a little sprinkle
and you don't want to go too heavy you
don't want to mouth full of paprika but
you do want enough to give you a pop of
color and really enhance that eggy
flavor and obviously i already had this
in the pantry so it's totally optional
if you don't want to use the paprika but
one is a deviled egg staple and two it
looks pretty right southern cooking is
about love right that's what everyone
says they're like ooh southern
hospitality you feel the love so let me
just give them a little love scallion
you just put a couple one or two on each
one look how cute they are you guys and
these things 90 cents a serving course
one
done all right let's move on to course
number two for my entree i am making
pimento
cheese quiche
hold for reaction i'm gonna be real with
y'all i've never made pimento cheese
quiche but doesn't it just sound good
and i think it'll pair well together i
ate pimento cheese entirely too much
growing up so i'm really excited to give
it a shot and see if i can make this
work so i have two pre-prepared pie
crusts so what i'm going to do is
actually roll these guys out until my
lightly floured surface and once you get
them all flattened on your
just give them a roll out we're going to
make them a little thinner and we want
them to cover our entire tart shell and
i'm actually going to gently lay the
girls in this pan just push down on the
sides so we get a nice tight fit they're
going to overlap but that's fine i'm
gonna press them together quiche is not
a super southern thing but it is one of
the first things i really got into when
i went to culinary school because
culinary school you know like french and
pimento cheese is what i grew up eating
so i'm really excited about this dish it
feels like where i should be right now a
really neat trick to trim away these
edges really fast is you take your
massive rolling pin and you just want to
roll it over the top okay this looks
good i'm just going to peel away it's
almost like taking off a face mask
except less gross so i have my girls in
the tart pan so i'm about to add my eggs
to the bowl and i'm going to add half
and half i'm going to use half and half
because we're broke and we can't afford
heavy cream this is southern so i'm
going to add a little bit more of
crystal and just a little salt because
everything needs to be seasoned and i'm
just going to give this a whisk make
sure i get all those yolks all broken up
pimento cheese is basically some kind of
shredded cheese it's typically cheddar
and you add little pimentos and
typically it has like mayonnaise and
garlic and it's like a dip but since
we're making a quiche we're going to
take those same ingredients and add them
to our egg mixture so i added my four
ounces of pimento i'm gonna add my
cheese and half of the scallions
mix the girls up
and then i'm going to very gently
lovingly carefully add this to my tart
pan
make sure we get our cheese in there
so this is our bougie pimento cheese but
i used to eat this growing up a little
kid sitting on the floor with her ball
of mayonnaise cheese pimentos and
crackers which is probably why most of
us have health problems because this is
a snack
so to finish off our beautiful pimento
cheese quiche i'm going to add about a
half cup cherry tomatoes and i'm gonna
put them cut side up this way when we
bake it you can see them you get that
beautiful pop of red and finally i'm
gonna take the rest of my scallions and
just put them across the top so the last
step is to put in the oven at 350 for 40
to 45 minutes and you have to let it
rest for 30 minutes we want to let it
set and let that custardy texture really
get all good and creamy one of my sides
is going to be candied bacon the only
thing southern about this is if you know
one thing about folks from the south we
will have some poke on our folk okay so
i'm gonna spray these because we're
gonna put these in the oven and the
sugar is gonna get all caramelized and
yummy and we wanna use as much bacon as
possible and make sure everybody gets
about two pieces i'm also not gonna use
all of my bacon because we're gonna use
it as a topping in our next dish this
dish is not about being healthy it's
called dollar dish not healthy dish so i
actually have two thirds cup brown sugar
and i'm just going to give them all a
liberal sprinkle across the top this
whole thing is all about stretching each
ingredient till it's last drop so i'm
actually just going to add a little bit
of pepper on top of my candy bacon quick
and easy the bacon is done we're going
to put these in the oven at 400 degrees
for about 22 to 24 minutes
[Music]
we need to balance out this meal we have
a lot of heavy things so i'm thinking
what is cheaper than a salad and since
we're going southern i am going to make
a wedge salad to save money we're going
to make our dressing ourselves so in my
bowl i am going to add a cup of
mayonnaise and i'm going to add a cup of
that half and half and before i add my
ranch to it i'm actually just going to
give this a whisk so i'm just going to
add the seasoning for my seasoning
packet
and that's it super easy super cheap
super simple so the next step is
obviously to cut our lettuce into wedges
i really like iceberg you know she's not
one of the sexier girls she's not kale
or spinach or even romaine i don't care
about that in the south it is 200
degrees in the summer at two o'clock i
want something with a high water content
so i'm going with icebergs
so to make sure i get fixed pieces i cut
them in half and then i cut them into
thirds
and we're just going to put it cut side
up you want to get that really pretty
yellow color in there you also want to
get the ridges facing up so that way
your dressing gets into it some of your
toppings get into it and you just want
to get a nice clean topping ugh it just
falls over the sides like oh my god it's
so beautiful so i have some nice crispy
bacon the same bacon from earlier one to
save money and two southern even our
phthalates have pork and i'm gonna add
my cherry tomatoes the same cherry
tomatoes from our pimento quiche so last
but not least we're gonna add more
scallions why because we have scallions
and i feel like a salad just isn't a
salad without a little bit of onion use
whatever you got but definitely some
onion you want the salad to have some
bite oh my god so the first time
i remember having a wedge salad my
family would go to this restaurant
called crystal river and they would
serve wedge salads but they wouldn't
have any dressing because the dressing
were in these super tall green bottles
full of ranch on the table you would
you would pull the cork out and then we
would just cover the salad and ranch and
have our soup it was perfect so we are
completely finished with our main course
our pimento chief quiche our candy bacon
and our wedge salads all came out to 218
per serving
i'm getting good at this and if we're
going to be southern then we need a
dessert for dessert i am gonna make a
peanut butter pie i am obsessed with
these so be prepared to have your mind
legit blown if you are a peanut butter
lover this is the coup de gras it's a
dessert
first thing i'm gonna do is add a cup of
powdered sugar to my cup of peanut
butter and whip it all together peanut
butter pie is just really really easy i
don't want to say it's so easy like
anybody could do it but honestly y'all
it is that easy this is something you
can have your kids make if you really
like peanut butter honestly you could
probably just pour the peanut butter in
the pie crust ain't that and i might i
actually only ever had peanut butter pie
when we would go to the that restaurant
that's somewhere we would go i mean oh
my god whenever someone graduated from
preschool or literally any excuse to go
to crystal river and get that big ranch
and that peanut butter pie we were down
for it you know it was like that's like
going out when you're in the fall you go
to a restaurant where you can get
seafood and large portions feed a family
for not that much money i have my
powdered sugar and peanut butter
concoction and then i'm just going to
add a teaspoon of vanilla and then while
this is going i'm going to slowly stream
in my half and half you don't want to do
it too fast because you will break it
and since you're not going to bake this
you want to make sure you get the
consistency just right in the beginning
that half a half is a dollar 98 which
sounds like nothing until you're doing
dollar dish so that's a really expensive
item and i've used it in my pimento
quiche and my ranch dressing and now the
peanut butter pie so we absolutely
stretched that thing as far as we could
so i'm going to scrape the sides of my
bowl and just make sure i have
everything really well incorporated and
then i'm going to fold in my whipped
cream we don't want to deflate it
because you want it to still have that
light airy texture and that's why we
fold it in versus mixing it in all right
i don't want to do too much and deflate
the girls so now i'm just going to add
this to my chocolate cookie crust which
is definitely a very very important part
you can do it in a graham cracker crust
but you don't get the same
feeling and then i'm just going to use
my little offset spatula just to smooth
it down some more because it's a no-bake
dessert right there won't be a whole lot
of change in this once you lay it down
all right so she's flat mama looks good
so i'm gonna chill this in the
refrigerator for about one to two hours
and just let it sit
so in this piping bag i have some
chocolate and i'm just gonna create some
cute little limes over the top it's on
top of our chocolate for our peanut
butter pie what's better than more
peanut butter right you know honestly i
haven't made a peanut butter pie in i
don't know how long but i might add it
back into the rotation you know and
finally to dress up our girl we're just
going to add a little bit of whipped
cream and we're done i'm really excited
to eat this one like i'm about to cheat
on my diet i'm not sorry about it this
pie is going to be 102 per serving so
here are all three courses of our
southern inspired brunch today i made
spicy deviled eggs wedge salads pimento
quiche candied bacon and peanut butter
pie we need a new challenge y'all like
i've just gotten way too good at this so
i'm gonna have one of my spicy deviled
eggs
oh my god it's so good it's time to get
some of this quiche it's kind of big
piece i'm not ashamed of
this that was a great idea
you guys i deserve this
it's perfect oh my goodness
i'm showing a lot of restraint here
all of this has been super delicious
thank you guys for watching i'm so happy
i got to elevate and share a little bit
of my culture with you guys during black
history month if you're from the south
you already know this is kind of how we
get down so please tag me if you make
any of this if you make a pie feel free
to send me one i will see you guys next
time bye
it's so good
[Music]
oh yes
[Music]
you